I met this dynamic eye doctor who had
this great idea to Train low-income
women to start their own businesses
selling glasses in their communities
around the world and I thought wow this
is a powerful idea for one thing there's
about a billion people on the planet
that don't have access to glasses and
we're like failing as a species when
eight hundred years since the invention
of glasses like not everybody has access
to them and I knew that a traditional
charitable model is not going to solve a
problem of that scale so this idea to
actually empower people to start their
own businesses selling glasses made a
ton of sense in particular by focusing
on women like you have this great
multiplier effect because all the
studies show that when women have access
to capital they tend to use on the
health and education of their children
whereas guys I guess tend to you know